blanche
mathieu cornette et laura ont précisé si
vous m'entendez et levé la main voilà
donc le tout est bon pour cette deuxième
partie
laurent précités et mathieu cornette
voilà donc avec nous qui nous a rejoints
en cabine voilà c'est parti pour cette
revanche et donc laurent frayssinet a
pris un gros ascendant la gagner oui
donc la défense des deux cavaliers sur
sur une ouverture italienne je crois que
ce type d'ouverture ou matthieu
bourrette avait gagné le voilà alors
mathieu collette a énormément étudier ce
ce début et il le joue
allô allô il le joue d'une manière
moderne c'est-à-dire avec le coût des
trois
alors que autrefois s'orienter plutôt
vers ces trois des quatre donc il a un
point fort au centre le pion à 4 kills
qu'il maintient très solidement par
détroit et il appelle ses s'en fou de
voir la chaîne le fou de cases blanches
est passé en c4 devant la chaîne ou 3
contrairement en fout de cases noires
des noirs qui lui est resté à nos sept
prisonniers de la chaîne c'est cette dé
6,5 alors il ne renonce pas un
à la lutte pour le pour le centre avec
avec ses trois des quatre îles la
différer simplement bon moment il jouera
des quatre donc le plan qu'on a vu deux
de laurent avec cavaliers h7 puis
cavaliers g5 et tout de suite menace
d'exploiter le clouage un fou g4 donc si
clouage ici sur le cavalier et la dame
noire
la dame blanche pendant ici
voilà petites questions au fou qu'est ce
que tu fais tu prends tout de suite là
c'est beaucoup je remplace par un autre
cavalier
on appelle ce coup poser la question le
coup est roi où le coudray questions au
fou qu'est ce que tu vas faire est-ce
que tu prends est-ce que tu t'en vas et
wes que tu t'en vas probablement voilà
cent c'est logique et incitant les
blancs a joué le coup g4 qui serait une
erreur puisqu'il y aurait cavaliers
jessains tran h3 avec échec et ensuite
on prend les pions g4 avec le fou des
fans d'art qui décalait cavaliers donc
ce serait une grosse erreur évidemment
et le fait qu'on ne puisse pas avoir le
fou en e2 que le fou soit passé au delà
de la chaîne berson d'inconvénients ici
c'est à dire qu'on ne peut pas défendre
la case f3 et donc le clouage pèsent si
la dame sort
eh bien il ya démolition de la défense
du rock donc et pour se soustraire au
cloud âge il faut jouer rouages depuis
g4 toujours rage 2 et g4 la roche 2 pour
protéger le temps de protéger le pion
rage 3 même si ça affaiblit quand même
la position de mme aubry
oui mais bon alors une autre solution
peut-être renault peut-être un peu plus
risqué mais ce serait de jouer le coup
des 4 et ensuite ont ramené le fou ces
quatre ans eux deux pour ceux des clous
et mais des quatre évidemment sa voix et
de gros soucis aux saintes il faut bien
calculer
non moi je dois il a joué le plan que je
l'attends ce que j'ai indiqué ont alors
déjà je crois et donc je pense que je
veux me soustraire à ce clouage
désagréable voilà je veux jouer quatre
pour que ce fou arrêtent de jeter de
compte utilisée de donc de de lorgner
lors disque le fou voilà on parle du le
reniement du faux lors du monde u c'est
très joli et oui le fou qui aimait oui
c'était dans les anciens traités du 19e
siècle que l'on écrivait la croix de la
tour larosace du cavalier
chants royal le rayonnement de la dame
et le fameux le reniement du fou parce
que c'est une pièce oblique comme le
gars qui lorgne qui jette un regard
oblique sur les choses il ya la notion
de regard oui ils sont fous regardant au
loin au loin il faut l'horizon alors
c'était marrant ce vieux traité que
j'avais lu il ya quelques temps qui
expliquait le l'ornement du fou le vieux
traité confluent du meilleur souple non
c'est non mais c'est bien traités sont
très intéressants parce qu'il ya plein
d'anciens thermes et puis sur le
l'histoire du jeu sur sur l'évolution du
jeu il ya beaucoup de choses à apprendre
des vieux livres bien sûr car les
modernes n'en fait que s'inspirer des
anciens qui ont connu des belles choses
et ça sent les précurseurs
on ne saurait pas tout ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui et ça je crois que beaucoup
de gens oublient ces choses-là on
retrouve c'est vrai aussi en
mathématiques d'ailleurs l'histoire des
mathématiques est intéressante aussi
pour comprendre les concepts comme
l'évolution du vin sont durs héros aux
sang et or de festin ouais évidemment ce
sont des concepts qui existe à un moment
donné de l'histoire et c'est vrai que
c'est intéressant de savoir pourquoi ce
concept est aimanté par exemple moi
c'était ça permet de mieux le comprendre
sous les voilà alors c'est que va jouer
frais signer pour pour améliorer ses
pièces elle que faire de cette dame des
huit qui est passive là au fond c'est
tous ensemble paniers sont pas encore
lié mais bon sur le plan le coup le kw à
5 et 7 permettrait loup et vous voyez le
kw à 5 a été très important parce qu'il
est mauvaise et oui sur les dames on
peut pas vraiment se dégager si on veut
se dégager mais y aura la prison b6 et
puis le pion à sera sur une colonne
ouverte la tour sera tout de suite
active et puissance à tour
après effectivement donc actives la
position noir manque de
de souplesse et là comment réaliser des
réponses la réponse voilà rouach 8 et 10
3 je suis bien sûr l'idée cftc f5 on
pouvait pas faire tout de suite parce
que tant que le roi était en g8 le fou
c4 boom taper sur leurs war et donc il y
aurait eu échec c'était un coup donc un
coup illégal
oui donc le coup f5 c'est toujours bon
et bien sûr roche 2 c'était pour jouer
les quatre donc g4 il aimerait
maintenant imposer un cavalier en f5
waouh cavalli h 15 voilà il le fait
parce que en cas de découverte
maintenant il ya cavaliers projet six
échecs avant il pouvait pas faire ce
coup à cause de cavaliers prend 1,4 il y
aurait eu fou prend h4 mais maintenant
le fait qu'il ait joué leroy nash 8 ya
l'intermédiaire câble et pranger 6e
siècle voilà donc qui peut jouer
cavalier h4 pour le mettre à 9,5 la
casse quand il arrivait qu'il faut
enlever le fou voilà tout simplement
voilà le menace car les kung fu chic
alors maintenant des fortes maintenant
f5 n'existe plus puisque il ya j'ai 4 4
et le cavalier 5 + 5 puisque il ya deux
trois défenseurs donc la position des
essais le cmem le match qu'on aide qui
vient oui non mais je suis là c'est un
c'est un classique c'était steintz qui
montrait sa danse est partie pression
dans ces espagnols y jouer régulièrement
h3g quatre cavaliers h45 et ensuite une
attaque sur le roi
décidément même pression que jamais mais
là c'est les vieilles idées de génie de
sa mère
la tour e est mal placé il va falloir la
ramener sur la colonne g ou sur la
colonne f tous ici vous voyez revenir
ici peut-être permis de valider h 4 gc
oui mais maintenant ça y est c'est clair
alors là c'est s'attaquer au droit dont
qui il a réussi à obtenir le type de
pollution qui souhaitait qu'il qu'il
aime et c'est là où il est le plus à
l'aise dans une attaque indirecte contre
le roi on l'a vu hier soir dans son
espagnols eux contre contre olivier
rhône et où dès qu'il a eu trois quatre
pièces sur le roi il ya eu ce 6e la
petite combinaison grosse combinaison
oui avec sacrifice du cavalier pour
finir gens qui voient pas très content
de son ouverture je pense donc laurent
n'est pas à l'aise dans cette ouverture
ça lui convient pas c'est pas c'est
d'ailleurs pourquoi commence d'ailleurs
autant il a trois minutes de retard et
c'est donc cavalier au cices le coût
normal ça donne et les chemises et le
trou f4 et on appelle un trou une case
incontrôlable par des pions c'est le
terme exact
un trou dans une position c'est une case
sur laquelle on peut aller avec une
pièce aussi contraindre voilà y'a pas
d'être chassé par un pion ni envie 3 il
est trop tard il est trop avancé et lee
en 3 puisque le point 4 est aussi trop
avancé donc en commun efficace ne serait
probable que par une pièce pour elle à
part le fou mais faudrait donc donner
une pièce à noter que maintenant il ya
des thèmes notamment sur la case h6 par
exemple dont il ne fait pas mine aurait
pu envisager des sacrifices puisque ça
fait deux pions pour la pièce et parfois
ça peut suffire
voilà dans mathieu a joué cavalier 3
pour faire le relais des cavaliers ils
ramènent un cavalier attention on est
quand même très beau cavalier fcf
tranquille bien possibilité de mettre
une tour en juin puis jouer des coups
comme g5 de rupture oui
bon à voir est ce que on va voir s'il en
faut signer teint est un bon défenseur
oui il va pouvoir doubler sur la colonne
g au bon moment et puis le fou le fou c4
leur n'y aura donc sur sur la case f7
lorsque lorsque le cavalier aura disparu
de six lancements réussis son ouverture
possible
voyez là pas il n'a pas une ouverture
donc là on est dans la même position
qu'il aime un jeu sans et ça c'est très
important d'amener l'adversaire dans une
position qu'il n'est même pas où il
n'est pas à l'aise là on peut parler
rhône au delà de la préparation des
joueurs et on est typiquement dans une
préparation sérieuse jours ont analysé
le jeu de la dernière d'un genou les
joueurs se connaissent bien ce sont 2
français du circuit du cirque
international maintenant ils ont les
parties des uns et des autres sont
disponibles sur internet sur les bases
de données et donc ils peuvent analyser
le jeu de l'adversaire
oui il se préparait et se préparer donc
il a elle devait savoir mais je pense
aussi qu un détail très important c'est
que freyssinet n'a besoin que d'une
nulle
oui donc il n'a pas besoin d'être
entreprenants dans cette partie il y a
un corps net en quelque sorte fait le
jeu c'est à toi de venir me chercher moi
je bouge pas trop
montre moi ce que tu sais faire donc il
y joue un peu les digues le mans le mans
il attend là nul lui suffit il est dit
que le meilleur moyen de faire aussi c2c
de jouer contre son style oui je joue
contre son style ou et même de décès de
formule séduit le meilleur moyen de
faire pire de perdre l'ouïe
attention c'est ce qui était arrivé à
capablanca contre l'ask air cavaliers
classés que la nul lui suffisait lors
d'un championnat du monde
et puis il avait perdu
donc cavalier de 9,4 f4 il faut si on le
prend tout de suite bon on concède la
paire de fou le centre commence à
s'ouvrir il est bien ce cavalier là il
et il est très bien c'est le label case
tout simplement comme d'hab d'innocents
de gagner un pion khalid louis dowler
très bien le problème de dames des 2 c c
qui aura poussé 5 points
peut-être tout simplement parce que je
sais que ce retour est pas on va voir ce
que le noir imprévue sur d'amd de sion
sur dam des deux parce que j'ai cinq
perdrait le pion h 6 5
oui on prend s'en prendre à un âge si on
reviendrait à 900 qu'est ce qui la prive
donc non il va peut-être repartir
tranquillement angers 6 mai ces six mais
attention sacrifice de notre ami
cornette savall inspiré s'appelle
inspiré ce pion h 1 h 6 face aux deux
pièces et donner une pièce pour prendre
depuis en la défense d'un roi qui donc
est très souvent c'est 1,6 ça voudrait
dire qu'on prendrait ce pion ici on
sacrifierait le foot par exemple vous
prend et après puis on prend d'un panda
reprend ainsi ses menaces menace matches
il faut les jouer
m6 va montrer pourquoi cavaliers protège
et le fou ne pourrait pas prendre
puisqu'il serait cloué le flash 7
c'est donc il faudrait jouer fouet pts 6
vous ici un sacha sachant qu'on ne
pourrait pas chasser la dame par fou g7
puisqu'il y aurait de me prendre les
sept matches donc ça permettrait
peut-être aux blancs d'amener une autre
pièce
ça ne lui plaît pas ça c'est je pense
que sur corrigé 6 c'est que le sacrifice
de de mathieu est dans l'air un suivi
ensuite il est dans l'air oui mais là
attention là aussi
il aurait pu en prendre puis toujours la
menace il faut prendre cavaliers
possible puisque la h cup n'est plus
foulé 5
oui mais tour g1 ça devient la colonne
chez par ces moments là qu'on g8 ne
pourra jamais exister à cause de fou
pref71 la force du fou une foule de
cases blanches invité ce midi
ouais la dame des deux donc on voit bien
la pression quand même en bas on va
quand même récapituler impressions ici
sur cette grande diagonale très
important aussi parce que le roi aura du
mal à s'échapper du coin ici donc il ya
encore une pression ici avec ce gros
cavaliers pourquoi gros parce qu'il est
d'abord il lassé de ces changer à tout
moment contre enfouies si il peut aussi
surtout attaqué la case les 7 et aussi
la case h6 permettant des sacrifices et
notamment si ce cavalier arrivé à sauter
pourquoi pas cette batterie dame fou
pour se sacrifier sur le pion à 6 voilà
ça c'est les thèmes généraux après il
faut calculer précisément c'est très
difficile de tout calculer mais là ma
journée à dieu est dans son élément
donc là petit coup tranquille de laurent
frayssinet il
il anticipe le cavalier et le fou
protège déjà la casse g7
voilà il anticipe la protège la jouerie
et surtout sur fou prendre cavaliers
pions prend fou dame prend il ya
peut-être fournis oui
on va dire valeur sûre en cavalier hayes
et puis on prend vie on prend dame prend
d'hommes en fou voilà il pourrait
peut-être jouer fou 1,5 pour le pour
enlever une lada il serait sûr et cloud
améliorer ou le roi il y aurait
cavaliers prendre qu'à faire cavaler
francs et avec des échanges généralistes
je ne sais pas bon allez je sais pas
mais enfin il ya aucune des quatre ans
j'étais mille bêtises parce qu'ils
avaient le plan des quatrième plan des
quatrième derby la case de 5
et puis un bep cap renders des spéciales
décès oui mais voilà il a ajouté quatre
pour pour jouer la variante ça vous
prend voilà il vient de jouer des quatre
d'accord sinon l'oral soulager sa décret
position avec la variante qu'on a donné
quatre cavaliers voilà donc la grosse
pression et y réalise aussi le thème du
début ces trois des quatre qu'il a
différé qui l'a dit fait une autre fois
orange ou et ça tout de suite ces trois
des quatre l'an l'aller l'italienne
moderne se joue au fc 4 puis détroit
puis ces trois haies des 4 ans diffèrent
voilà on sait 4 ces caractéristiques de
la partie et ensuite a sévi dans la
partie oui et là aussi je pense qu'en ce
temps-là cette structure ici ces trois
des quatre que donc utiliser souvent
joue très tôt dans la partie qu'il a
effectivement il a pris le temps de la
jouer il a l'air très à l'aise ce type
voilà je pense que ce qu'il a étudié ça
avec prier parce qu'on reconnaît la
patte de prier là qui est oui eric priet
qui en là il priait est un entraîneur
national qui s'est occupée des équipes
de france des jeunes et qui a entraîné
les deux joueurs d'ailleurs il a
entraîné freyssinet pendant quelques
années il a entraîné mathieu cornette
aussi quand il avait été sélectionné par
la ffe donc
la fédération française des échecs donc
on reconnaît la patte de prier qui adore
jouer ces systèmes là où on a
l'impression qu'il fait pas quelque
chose et puis le fait quelques temps
après il a un peu endormi le joueur en
place entre d'abord ces pièces puis
après en intervenant passionnant c'est
parti on vous rappelle quand même que
c'est important pour moi je connais de
la gagner il reste quatorze minutes à
mathieu doit gagner impérativement vente
ajoutant aussi pour mathieu cornette
avantage shoichi qui on l'a signalé avec
ce gros cavaliers f500 cette pression
quand même à la fois maintenant au
centre ici avec cette tension les deux
points centraux 4 et des cats et deux
pions ici oui pression donc avec le
cavalier sur les cassettes sur la case
h6 lavatories d'amour fou qui pose des
problèmes ou là je suis parti ici sur
cette diagonale avec une carrière 4 qui
a l'air d'être totalement instable et
donc gros avantage pointu cornette qui
s'ils l'emportent et bien réussi à
revenir dans le match et plus or ils
vont être signés au départage à l'orgue
la d51 coup un coup thématique un coup
thématique très intéressant de la
position il profite aux racines et du
fait que le cavalier toujours en f4 pour
attaquer le fossé 4 il a probablement
que mathieu cornette va prendre
maintenant le cavalier attention il ya
le foot
il ya de fous ces quatre attaqué et on
pourrait sacrifier le fou c'est qu'après
t'attaquer etc
le pion la menace attention la menace
noir est double et puis on prend lyon 24
qui déstabiliserait le cavaliere celles
qui n'auraient pu son soutien centrale
n'aurait plus pu plonger mais on n'a pas
envie de prendre du plomb j'ai ici parce
que ça affaiblir et drôlement le roi
alors le fameux coup des cinq qui est le
coup thématique des libération des noirs
dans les parties du pied en roi 4,5 le
fameux coup les circuits la de laurent
frayssinet retour sur l'échiquier contre
coup oui lorsque les noirs peuvent
arriver à placer le le coc libératoire
des 5
on dit qu'ils ont fait un grand pas vers
l'égalisation basculer la partie qui
souvent aussi que quand l'initiative se
développe sur une aile comme ici il faut
réagir au centre c'est la réaction et la
réaction de laurent frayssinet ne s'est
pas fait attendre
il va profiter leur a fait signer pour
faire de gros échanges centraux et alors
si il sort à peu près bien
matériellement de cet échange de cette
de cette bataille quitte à en regarder
la bataille il ya des prises ici ici ici
[Musique]
ça fait beaucoup de prises ya aussi le
fois je sais tu qui peut prendre un f5 à
tout moment ça fait beaucoup de choses
il ya le cavalier c6 aussi qu'ils
contrôlent en d4
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de choses
beaucoup de choses à calculer mais si
les noirs s'en sortent
eh bien ils vont être même mieux
pourquoi ils vont être mieux et bien
parce que le roi blanc ici est affaiblie
du fait qu'on a bougé des pions orange 3
et g4 et donc il a on voit bien qu'il ya
des trous un côté du roi blanc et donc
au final si laurent frayssinet arrive à
ouvrir la position au centre ils
risquent de sortir avec un avantage
conséquent leurs pions prend des singes
voilà c'est le cool normal elle reprend
du car les superbes donc il a réussi
alors maintenant la question qui se pose
c'est est ce que les banques peuvent
sacrifier
voilà le jamais mathieu cornette à
préserver le fou le case blanche
le fameux food attaque donc puis on
prend 1,5
attention le cavalier donc oui oui un
tempo sur le cavalier maintenant qu'on a
pris et voilà donc il prend bien sûr il
donne sous le casque noir mais il a
réservé son full case blanche
ici dans prendra corps donc voilà donc
il faut pas parler on vous demande de ne
pas parler dans la salle merci parce que
vous gêner les joueurs
donc merci de ne pas parler pendant les
coûts et de rester sagement concentrés
voilà parce que vous gêner les joueurs
va les emmener de nous signaler
merci de ne pas parler alors attention
donc le pion au sein d'un attaque le fou
et 6 donc voilà donc finalement et bien
et bien l'origine et semble pas s'en
sortir correctement de cet échange
centrale oui là il a gardé la paire de
faux il a gagné la paire de faux
qu'entre oui pour le prix d'un pion en
dit qu'une paire de fulham et riant mais
cette affaire de fous ne peut pas rester
vivante on est bien d'accord puisque
c'est parce que le feu s'était enfermé
oui et puis le fond noir n'a pas de case
sur toutes les cases il était chargé
voilà la contre attaque face inuh centre
a fait long feu
non qu'ils donnent le full case blanche
moi je pense qu'il va en prendre le full
cases noires parce qu'ils ont le tempo à
angers c'est bien sûr il dans le tempo
et donc ensuite ils prendront le fou de
cases blanches ou m6 on peut prendre à
l'ap 5 et lorsque le fou partira jouer à
psy donc je pense qu'il va jouer ça pour
jouer abscisse bien sûr car le fou sera
sera parti est toujours f6 rouge et cinq
cavaliers prend et f4 peut-être
peut-être
sur dame prend peut-être f4 il ay la
colonie et lui mènera alors la colonne
chez pour travailler avec tour g1 ou g2
et les deux filets et le duo de pions
[Musique]
effet à un intérêt bon je pense qu'il
faut qu'il joue faux g5 oui sinon il ya
m6 très fort oui sinon à huis clos
bien sûr pas si l'europe est un petit
coin intermédiaire d'accord tour clou
sur la dame
mais si le pion prend le fou est bien la
dame est perdue donc voila un petit
thème faut il aimer mes gros soucis
quand même oui c'est possible sur faux
problème 77 tours cet os 6 oui pas mal
même fou aussi ouais ouais pas mal pas
braver de man font aussi pas mal
il va falloir sacrifier la qualité je
pas mal d'accord sacrifier la gagner
pas mal fou pref 7 5 qu'est ce qui est à
voir surtout ça qu'il faut faire sans
doute sur port au prince est ce qu'on
peut jouer cavalier prendre 5
intermédiaire cavaliers prendre 5
intermédiaire sur fou point f set il a
joué cointat d'abord attaqué à la wii
avec sa tour d'accord oui bien sûr à la
dame est obligé d'aller d'aller aux
fraises donc la foux prend f7 va être
très fort parce que sur 27
oui il y avait peu en prend puisque la
dame était défendu deux fois par le pion
et 3 et la tour des dames 7 ne marchait
pas donc maintenant il va jouer vous
prend au fctt et je pense que ça va très
mal pour laurent rouy la la il est
expulsé du centre est on le voit le
centre appartient en pièces blanches et
le ku'damm et 8
vous voyez il faut aussi savait tempo
sur la dame gagner du temps donc là je
crois que cette partie je m'excuse pour
n'être jamais quelques donneurs sur un
oui moi je mettrais un peu plus haut
mais attention puisque battu connaître
six ans est sorti hier face à olivier
rhône et on peut très bien voir leurs
enfants fascinés s'en sortir aussi où tu
as aidé quand même écrasé regardez comme
ils écrasent il est quand même regarder
replier sur trois colonies si oui mais
avec deux pions énorme ici il a réussi
il a pas réussi à tenir face à la
pression il s'est fait un peu débordé
dans cette ouverture
tu connais tu as réussi à lui imposer
son style en vrai c'est la partie et la
préparation d'un tournoi semble super
héros menace dans cette partie comme
l'aspirant prend m6 qui est la menace
directe en 30 fou c'est la menace
directe à 24 il a préféré oui ils
attaquaient pts ils attaquent f2 il ya
des e-menaces d'emprunt pions échec une
équipe a une vraie menace un prix moyen
après trois chiens il ya pas grand chose
il ya un fou de moins
si si si parce que sur qui on prend et
fils d'un problème de lloret tour
printemps prend tout reprendre pour
prendre ça valait rien bon il peut aussi
jouer moi j'ai deux le coût tranquille
est plein et pas avoir à s'embêter avec
une dame qui parce qu'il y ait un peu
oui mais la position est déjà très
compromise
donc je ne sais pas ce que va pouvoir
trouver fait signer maintenant l'un
écrasé pas ce qui va ce qui va trouver
donc le roi g2 est vraiment le coup
tranquille et bien sa matière on ne peut
de défense autour du roi en décidant
pour l'instant fait un grand prix
comment dirais-je très très risqué
oui regarde neuf minutes comme bon là il
faut qu'ils d'avril maintenant est-ce
que ce qu'il va wipro cavalli prend oui
là je pense qu'il va y avoir il va y
avoir tout reprendre et puis il faut
prendre f7 ton prof ou preuve cette et
d'am-dam d'abord puis et puis là ces
bateaux prochaine qu'on regarde et on va
se faire mater quant à lui et il va se
faire mater et bien mesdames les maths
et le fou c4 empêche ici le roi de
sortie en fait joli tableau de matin
dans la foulée monstration d'attac
partie d'un tacle de mathieu plus court
mais dense en beauté des rues vous
pouvez le voir le roi n'a hélas plus de
cases pour pouvoir
donc les deux joueurs posent entre les
deux belles démonstrations autant dans
la première physiquement que dans la
seconde 2 blitz à 5 minutes par jour
je vous rappelle que les joueurs vous
offrir un spectacle d'autant plus
intéressant que vous ferez du silence
qu'est ce qui laissait passer le regard
le regarde patrick besse quand il a
demandé le silence aux spectateurs un
regard inquisiteur presque avec un
reproche très très très très marqué donc
attention attention aux spectateurs qui
fera du bruit parce que l'arbitré semble
extrêmement déterminé à faire le calme
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a caché dans ses
boîtes sur sa table attention je ne
voudrais pas être celui qui découvre qu
est ce qu il a caché une matraque un
pistolet voilà donc on va passer à la
partie donc maintenant blix donc on est
encore en départage décidément ce grand
prix se décide en départage ça va être
sûr c'est le cinquième match évidemment
cette demi-finale après les quatre
quarts de finale et bien ça sera le
quatrième match décidé
[Musique]
au départage tous les matches sont
idéaux des partages sauf le match de
laurent frayssinet qui a gagné 2 0 son
premier quart de finale son quart de
finale face à marc lehu mec
hier à 17 heures mais sinon tous les
matchs donc y compris cette demi finale
se sont décidés en n'ai pas réussi à
départager géant sera donc c'est bon et
en place là on est en place c'est la
première partie je peux dire c'est bon
c'est bon julien le temps le temps des
planches quand on déclenche la pendule
ce que c'était monsieur freyssinet qui
avait commencé avec les blancs les
partisans des belles parties d'échecs
dynamique et vivant ce sera ma cliente
n'est pas qu'ils conduisent c'est bon
c'est bon pour la pendule se déclenche
quand on démarre en quand on démarre la
pendule ça va se déclencher
voilà qu'on est à cinq minutes voyaient
quatre minutes 50 contre 5 minutes voilà
de vitesse donc renouvelle donc là quand
même là tu connais tu avait démarré le
match avec les noirs ils démarrent les
départage avec les blancs alors nouvelle
italienne même variante mais tout de
suite rouach 8
ouais j'apprends par mais des gestes
voilà j'apprends par mail et fait tout
de suite précaution et sur la vente de
plants et m5 réalisé près vie pour la f5
très vite
j'attends pas pour faire nul dans celle
là voila voila je joue les re veut je
voudrais tout de suite
nerveux alors la tête il s'est trompé de
plans même peut-être laurent fossiles
tout à l'heure oui bah il y pensait que
la nuit lui suffisait donc il voulait
pas aller chercher le corps net qui
s'était trompé de plans tout cas c'est
une demi finale passionnante entre les
deux locaux de l'épreuve donc mathieu
quand on est le bordelais les deux
talents régionaux loupé de les vingt
dernières années
maître international de l'histoire de
bordeaux depuis que bordeaux existe avec
en même temps que bordeaux existe depuis
des milliers d'années le seront plus à
exister au moins 2000
même si au début c'était un tout petit
village il rentrait signer lui était le
premier grand maître international
aquitain ils viennent de dax laurent
frayssinet même si maintenant il vit à
paris mais il a été formé à dax et
habite inhabitat dax depuis tout petit
voilà les échecs régionaux je crois
d'ailleurs qui est en trois nuits il
faut par an pour faire une simultanée
exceptionnel vous voyez pas dans son
club d'origine pour garder un peu le
contact avec ses racines dans la rampe
pour addax voilà donc il fait une oeuvre
un peu de militantisme aussi en offrant
sept simultané ce qui est un honneur
évidemment parce que c'est pas donc ça
y'est cavaliers pro f 6 et la hongrie le
fou d'avoir comme ça un grand maître qui
accepte qu'un qui
simultanée nos régions ont du talent
canadien c'est leur cavalier cette
attaque à la fois le roi d'un des huit
ce qui s'appelle une fourchette
fourchette mais on voit bien la
fourchette 1 1ere 2e dans de la
fourchette fourchette à dos dans oui
mais voilà et le cavalier est défendue
par le fou c'est qu'à mes défauts les
fourchettes à trois dents oui donc les
échecs régionaux wii qui ont produit ces
deux talents des 5 voilà l'idée c'est
quoi évidemment des cinq est logique on
reprend au centre et on attaque le fou
ici et comme ça on intercepte donc four
b3 des gones a débloqué alors oui là il
faut il faut échanger mathieu a raison
il faut absolument qu'il n'y est plus
depuis ensemble trop pour que les fous
puisse dégager leur lors leur puissance
d'attaqué c'est de fulham bien sûr vous
plus de trois quarts des fonds pour les
blancs qui réussit encore oui position
ouverte avec les essais libres il est
plaisant pour les blancs ces quatre là
il faut absolument casser les pions
blancs les pions blancs pour se mettre
au service de la paire de fonds voyez
sacrifice sacrifice battu corn et il va
donner une pièce décidément il bouscule
laurent frayssinet pétition les jeunes
n'ont aucun respect dans ce grand prix
avec deux minutes 47 ne pouvait pas
prendre des 5
il a depuis un an pour la pièce et puis
la fragiliser la position ne nous
arrange pas compris pourquoi pas prendre
la vallée grand dessein qu'est ce qui se
passait a peut-être tout simplement tout
reprendre qu'à 3
oui si donc les blitz sont difficiles à
suivre parce que ça va très vite
regarder deux minutes mail de 3,30 ne
faut pas oublier que frayssinette un
spécialiste du bit juges du tpi sur 32
bits champion de france donc là le match
qu'on échoue face à un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde en blitz a ordonné le
supplément évidemment beats le temps ici
2011 contre 3 minutes de regarder comme
vous voyez une minute voilà ça fait
beaucoup gagnante lycées beaucoup
attention c'est un cran compte experts
du bit se rendre aussi les quatre
voiliers petits petit coup de patte la
de la fourchette à 4 dans we 24 dans
deux trois quatre pièces bon là c'est
horrible mais vous savez pas par la
qualité
oui qu'est ce qu'il va faire il a le
temps de perdre les x 7,6 sur le foot
tout simplement
voilà c'est ce qu'il fait et oui le flou
car il y envoyer la menace se faisait
opérer les cases pour le foot et la
menace subsiste
- l'intermédiaire de fasciner énorme il
n'a pas vu mathieu cornette c'est sûr
oui oui a tout vu de rentrer ce qu'il
est il va être à eelv a donné le fou
contre le cavalier voilà ça n'est pas se
sauver de la fourchette mais attention
attention et sa paire la dame une erreur
de faire cavalier chèque
pourquoi de renault et bien tout
simplement parce que sur kelly échec on
ferait tout reprendre oui voilà tout
reprendre et la yahama restera
évidemment reste attaqué par le fou et
on ne peut pas faire d'impasses on ne
peut pas faire non plus tout reprend fou
oulala c'est très triste à cause de la
même variante très tendue solitude 40
contre 12 30 il rendait la pression sont
en avance évidemment laurent est en
avance ni des clous ou tout simplement
des clous il est laissé déjouer le coup
le plus tranquille et il menace le fou
et menace de simplifier la police il a
repris la paire de fou donc si la
position simplifie attention attention
il ya le il ya deux pions des ja le pian
des qui est une arme chez les blancs là
le pian des libres il faut pas oublier
qu'il ya deux pions pour le cavalier que
lecavalier est encore passif donc pour
l'instant là pour l'instant le
le matériel voit la pression sur la
colonne des équilibres la position ils
avancent leurs pions des lampions des
bons il faut il faut je suppose ramener
le cavaliere bloqueurs un peu ton tour
puis on prend il ce pur maintenant
hilton poison très puissant ce pion à
des menaces de m'atteler pion avancé ici
le roi est faible entre cinéma je vais
contrôler roi donc les comment dirais-je
les mouches ont changé d'âne
oui et puis de temps laurent frayssinet
qui attaquent 5 kg près c'est aussi une
grosse erreur h5 renom j'ai peur hc
matthew cornette que le coup simple coup
comme on trouve quatre ans par exemple x
4 après c'est le cas au niveau pour
venir manger 5
parce que là on joue en jeu celle qu'on
a laissé cette case oui mais rien n'est
clair il va peut-être aussi joué voilà
vous le 4 et protège le web
il a peut-être joué six aussi pour
continuer à faiblir le roi est tout
aussi way
adam 3 tient qu'à valider mais vrai
cavalier
5 bien joué frottez je le fais un voyage
un aaa voilà attention là j'avais pensé
alors un tour des cinq qui étaient
peut-être un coup jouable mais y'avait
dame à un échec
c'est tendu menace tout simplement de
prendre l'option de cette voie là il le
réalise quand même la côte tour des cinq
ils profitent du flou âge maintenant qui
a pu enfin attention
[Musique]
alors là peut-être oui h6 bien jouer à 6
puis ensuite il jouera tours 5
oui oui c'est très très intéressant se
présente et récents sur faut prendre
tour ben hilli adam 8 non pas huit
échecs dames 8 échecs des dames 8 échecs
aussi non
mais d'un budget qui a damé fut tout
simplement alors dame prend 3 comprend
on prend
quatre échecs ou de le faire maintenant
des quatre échecs ah oui là il n'a pas
le rater je ne baisse pas le rater mais
ses chéquiers matin il ne veut pas le
rater oui des big three ce match bien
sûr dès que le roi ce truc que le roi
n'a plus de défense de pions ce que
c'est réalisé à faire mathieu cornet ta
joie
si c'est pendant le dernier défenseur g7
n'a plus suffi de deux trois pièces et
ont pour les organiser pour les as
raison je vous rappelle pour la énième
fois de ne pas discuter et parler
pendant les parties ça distrait les
joueurs se concentrent moins bien et
vous offriront un spectacle de moins
bonne qualité
nous allons remettre en place les pièces
la pendule et cette fois ce sera laurent
frayssinet qui devra jouer avec les
blancs et devra impérativement
l'emporter pour espérer disputer la mort
subite contre mathieu corps mais alors
qu'on montre ici le le mat
voilà qui vient de se faire alors il
suffit maintenant d'un nul à mathieu
cornette pour se qualifier
incroyable incroyable peut-être
finalement c'est que c'est des surprises
depuis ce début de ce grand prix oui
dans le jeu rapide
le joueur qui est le plus aigu
tactiquement et le plus dangereux dans
les blitz et dans les parties rapides et
mathieu est un joueur tactique
exceptionnelle qui qui calcule très vite
et qui sent la force d' attaques des
pièces alors peut-être un signe c'est
que il est sur scène lui alors que alors
il vient de sortir maintenant mais il
était sûr
et on dit toujours que le dompteur et
dans la cage avant les lions donc
peut-être c'est lui qui va doter notre
ami freyssinet incroyable tout à fait
tout à fait ce que là il al'avantage le
premier blitz gagnait deuxième beats la
pression et doit absolument gagner s'ils
cornette l'emporta s'apprécie n'est que
et que edward le jeune aussie vertolaye
ce serait le triomphe de la jeunesse ce
qui est ce qui se passe actuellement
dans les échecs depuis une trentaine
d'années c'est les jeunes qui qui tient
la dragée haute à tous les joueurs
d'expérience sur le voit dans les
champions du monde et dans tous les
tournois
enfin même s'il faut signer encore jeune
mais bien sur quel âge il a 24 ans 25
ans mais il ya des plus jeunes que les
jeunes elle est plus jeune que les
jeunes mathieu connaît depuis hier donc
à 20 ans et romain edouard lui à peine
16 voyez donc le tournoi va être gagné
par romain edouard qui va battre
freyssinet en finale c'est ça le battre
mathieu cornette qui avortent mathieu
connaître un final lequel aura éliminé
facile et la logique c'est ça c'est le
plus jeune le plus jeune gagne tout cas
ça semble être la logique de ceux de ce
grand prix et des échecs un général avec
l'éclosion de tous les talents qui en
ski c'est incroyable c'est la façon dont
ma tuque on était revenu à la fois hier
face à olivier rooney est aujourd'hui
face à face à laurent frayssinet par sa
force tactique par la force tactique
mais c'est quand même extraordinaire
parce que leur offre aussi des réputé
pour être un moment de rencontre et là
quand il a eu sa pièce de plus il payer
les dépenses la borne d'âge autant voilà
deuxièmes louis plaud dire les deux
combattants alors on va regarder comment
les joueurs vont se concentrer sur cette
source au blitz à la une se serrer la
main
on est toujours fair-play évidemment les
joueurs quelle tension quelle tension il
faut absolument maintenant que laurent
frayssinet quand même grand favori de ce
grand prix 2007 et bien arrive à
l'emporter dans ce dernier bis face à
matthew bourne est non seulement
l'emporter uniquement pour rester en
course parce que ça lui donnerait
non pas la victoire mais simplement la
possibilité de jouer le dernier bis de
départage la la quel match décidément
depuis hier voilà un match au couteau
après des matches au couteau à peu près
le même système oui le même système
quasiment que dans la partie sauf qu'il
récupère tout de suite ce pion il n'a
pas le temps d'organiser une belle
partie stratégique
donc il est obligé l'un d'eux permet au
plus pressé de l'équilibré le matériel
pour 4 il ya l'air surpris lui ont fait
signer de ce coup parce qu'il avait ses
classiques pourtant cette idée
oui 3
cavalli 17 de la part de mathieu
cornette voyez un système est
intéressant encore à [ __ ] ou c3 et
donc il veut jouer sans doute le
caméléon d2 et non pas en c3 sinon
j'aime toujours en société que mes
flèches on up net le cavalier ici ces
huit tours s'est vite pour préparer la
réaction en simple par ces 5 4 1
pourtant mon cachet bien sûr empêcher
ces cinq définitivement voilà ça fait
deux pions qui verrouille 7,15 qu'elle
ait des cinq de mathieu cornette à 3
olivier rouyer complètement la casse et
voilà donc ça s'est il est tranquille
mais ce côté là il faut l'emporter
laurent fasciné faux pas face à voile
assez cavalier très puissant en d5 pas
simplement jouer pour lui s'il pouvait
se maintenir en d5 ses cavaliers à st je
n'ai pas subir quatre un jour où la lapd
on prend 6,5
décidément ça y va il a laissé tout de
suite ouvertures de lignes retardé
développement chez les blancs pourquoi
il a pris à un symbole aussi c'est
bizarre parce qu'ils contrôlent et à
casser ça qu'il allait essayer surtout
que il a laissé faire mathieu
connaissent ce coût à quelque chose de
pabos un b prend 1,5 et en dire général
que quand un coût n'est pas beau il ya
quelque chose qui est pas bien derrière
éviter de jouer des coupes à beauvais
des couples t'as beau pas être au bout
donc le coup ces cinq-là réaction
normale au centre ça y est quatre vingt
quatre en même pas deux mais quatre en
même temps dans la laure picat c'est
très embêtant
il a joué d'avancé 8-4 bien sûr l'avion
prend pions prend l'envié on le prend à
protéger par le cavalier et aussi par le
fouet cette wii wheel assez dure comme
on met il un pion à ses protégés par la
tour
oui donc un candidat ici pour aller à
dame alors protégé par la tour donc
c'est cette réforme comme l heure le
fameux pions passé qui quelquefois aulas
oui mais c'est une qualité
il laisse la qualité ils rentrent ici
des jeunes sortir mais ils laissent la
qualité oui donc je disais que
quelquefois le pion passé était un
peintre est passé en fait signer à
leernes auront pleinement complètement
en dehors du coup dans cette dans ce
match le métro tour ces trois dames à 4
voilà les noirs où il ya la lie
attention il suffit d'une nulle ou noir
il suffit d'une île au noir est là et
comment et la dame
la dame me manque comme des pieux de
qu'un petit peu d'air la p3 bada maroc
un petit peu d'air mais il n'a pas pu la
qualité donc non non mais il laisse avec
ces pièces mauvaise et passifs
voilà il il peut la reprendre à tout
moment parce que j'y rejoue vous les
trois maintenant trois ils attaquent la
tour donc terrible ce match cornet t il
prendre la qualité à sonneurs voilà
quand il le souhaitera
damas huit dames 1 8 aux dames invite
moi j'aime pas trop ce coup là ce
vis-à-vis avait le fou j'ai deux je ne
sais pas peut-être frais cinéma trouver
quelque chose là dessus
ouais c'est vrai mais il veut attaquer
le pion à 5
oui il doit travailler ses qualités en
fait il faut dit il aux foulées de la
force et là il va falloir prendre se
décider pour prendre la qualité est là
alors le faire parce que sinon la tour
est vite allé en c1 il faut se décider
et dont il compare non il fait pression
ça il fait d'abord pression
intermédiaire en fait un 26 kw
intermédiaire six points intermédiaires
fait pression sur le pion une menace
évidente ou rebond qu'avait louis et en
cas de toux reprend pied on prend et il
y aura peut-être aussi le clouage
surtout revient au moins deux choses si
on prend nos valeurs et puis le cas il
pourra clouer le cavaliere tourbe et 8
décidément il vous des coûts très
inattendue depuis le début il prend pas
il prend jamais non mais se contente de
regarder autant de minutes français
équivalent à rendre ses rivales en
équivalent de temps cette équipe alors
mais là il est à son aise parce que ces
pièces sans qu'il a pris en trois ses
pièces en tout un jeu tout libre donc le
couteau
ces huit n'ont finalement il prend 3
prend finalement il prend donc il a une
qualité il va se prendre un tour s'est
vite probablement probablement la tour
va venir en jeu wii activer la tour avec
tempo pion à 3 d'abord un chèque d'abord
le fameux petit coin intermédiaire le
petit pont qui n'oublie pas le petit
intermédiaire décidément puis le coin
que l'on attendait tous mais avant le
couple attend tous église toujours un
petit truc une petite précision ce qui
fait décalage une petite précision
décidément donc introduction des pièces
lourdes menaces dame ces deux fêtes
matthieu bourrette ont remis technique
dans ce tournoi c'est de se faire
dominer pour après asséné
oui la surprise du chef c'est à dire dès
qu'il est pas trop à l'aise il joue un
peu timoré ce qu'il a fait dans la
première partie on l'a vu mais dès qu'il
lâche ses poids lourds à transmettre ces
pièces dans le jeu et qui sait tirer
parti de tomber 8 de l'activité ces
pièces il ya donc fait fort attaque là
j'étais forcé comme madame oui oui sinon
il y avait tourbe et 8 gagnant une place
des trois d'accord très bien ah c'était
l'idée de frais s'il ya toujours 3 qu'il
faut oui peut-être qu'il va changer les
dames avantage noir toujours pas ce
qu'il y avait à changer les dames
il ya là qu'on a essayé change les dames
se disant mais j'ai foi dans dans mon
matériel de plus il ya sept tours cette
tour chez nos matériels menace à deux
donc qu'il faut il faut prendre il faut
jouer les faux chromé 4 à 6 1 c'est
foutu même s'il faut tuer ainsi je pense
que je pense que le fameux pions passé
devient alors que je disais tout à
l'heure le pire est passé
terminé donc ce pire on va être attaqué
et manche et voilà deux maintenant
s'asseoir c3 c3 pour faire donne pour
faire damer gagné une pièce est simple
donc ici je pense qu'il va y avoir
cavaliers b61 cavaliers mais 8c puis
ensuite attaque du cpie rue puis en le
carnet d'ordres s'est fini c'est
finalement fait signer le pian 2 tombe
est foutue reste une minute vingt
minutes 36 et bien mathieu cornette
auront réussi à damer le pion c'est le
cas de le dire au champion et
vice-champion d'europe de blitz comme
layar rien à faire envoyer cavaliers 5
bon ça y est elle est fausse et si ce
miracle on sait jamais non là il va
jouer tout il ya eu un miracle hier
moi je pense qu'il aurait pu jouer tour
c'est 8 avait l'idée tour cn itie
cavalier polisse intéressant qu'est-ce
qui se passe non mais là il va jouer
tant c'est un échec
tous ses 30 ans et 3 aussi à plusieurs
cook et moi ton c'est un chèque tour
c'est un oui je l'aï dit je suis content
qu'il ait joué tour c'est assez terminer
un petit coin esthétique
eh bien c'est la surprise de cette demi
finale c'est mathieu cornette qui
s'impose à nouveau dans ce blitz donc
victoire du match pour mathieu cornette
si voilà donc effectivement combattre il
a dit c'est la deuxième surprise du chef
que nous a réservé mathieu corner
mathieu cornette vainqueur de cette
demi-finale police et le boîtier à un
match qu'avec avait mal démarré avec
cette défaite est clair et puis
finalement un gros gros retour et puis
alors cette démonstration en 8es la
partie numéro d'accès blanc m'a mis en
confiance c'est attaquer et à la fin
dans quelques chanceux sur la tête la
première jeter la pierre honnêtement il
y avait des associations pour la pièce
laurent peut-être alors c'était
difficile en impression que mathieu a
réussi à tam mené sur son terrain avec
cette italienne se fout c4 avec ses
variantes l'a peut-être un léger souci
pour ces règles dans le deuxième celui
intrigue dont il a fait la veille a cédé
aux pressions
j'aurais dû jouer avant que joue
d'habitude que je jouais dans huit c'est
joli aucun problème pour être sûrs pour
la c1 après le premier semi rapides et
donc ça va jouer le tuto et après dans
le vide on peut l'applaudir à laurent
fausse idée merci d'avoir suivi cette
première demi finale donc on retrouvera
laurent frayssinet puisqu'il jouera
quand même la troisième place à 20h ce
soir avant la grande finale à 22h qui
donc verra jouer mathieu cornette cette
grande finale 2007 face au vainqueur du
match qui viendra tout à l'heure entre
alberto d'avis
[Musique]